so as soon as the technology component
was accessible which was kind of an it's
kind of an outreach thing you know so
like we went in and to test the validity
of like what it was going to mean to put
this together we made sure that there
were existing technologies
in different sectors that could do what
we needed to do
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to the sea well two ships meet
josh bremmer the ceo and co-founder of
komodo covers a marine accessories
company that is bringing a new wave of
innovation to the marine industry
[Music]
josh grammer welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you very much for joining
me today how are you good how are you
doing i'm doing great i'm i'm excited to
talk to you about innovation in the
boating industry about you know the
entrepreneur that you are in sort of
your journey and what you're doing today
and and the way that you're that you're
bringing the entrepreneurial
entrepreneurial world to your domain and
so it'll be a fun conversation
have you always been in boating in in
this sort of space
you know i've always been and you know i
was in the kitchen and then
simultaneously in the action sports
industry so
growing up my grandparents
lived on the lake that i live on now and
so my dad grew up on the lake you know
the neighbors were building water ski
jumping skis in the basement
trying to decide with slalom skiing
whether the boat should just go faster
the line should go shorter so my entire
life
from the time i was a year old or even
less you know i was sitting in the boat
with my dad while they were water skiing
with my grandma
and so we've always been big water
sports activities people mainly focused
in that water sports realm
so i've been on boats since i was born
well and and sort of the entrepreneurial
aspect of it of identifying you know the
you know different things you can do
within the boating space was this always
a part of you or or is this something
that is sort of you know idea-led and
then the entrepreneurship team
you know
i've i we just really got upset about
boat covers
i think that was the long and short of
it it's like they just didn't work you
know and that was
that was the main driving force to
going out and starting our own thing and
inventing this product from the ground
up you know i had come from you know i
was in the kitchen i was a chef and then
i was a manager and so i've had a lot of
management experience
but
i had never really done it all by myself
and i still don't to this day you know
but for the first time ever it's 100
percent my fault all the time
and so that's been pretty interesting
but
i think it was just time to jump you
know i mean everyone always is
interested in these interviews like how
did you know it was the right time i was
like well i had had enough
of everything else and it was just time
for me to move forward so let's just
work with our idea so so let's take a
step back and share with me a little bit
about your experience so what you know
what what it what are both covers how do
you interact with them in the day-to-day
and then what really
led you to the place of saying you know
what i think there's a place for me to
innovate here and instead of being a
consumer i can actually be a producer
right i'd love to understand that shift
of mentality of of sort of what journey
you went on from using it to actually
saying i'm going to be to to try and be
a market leader here
well the main problem was is you know as
the boats got nicer like we started off
with like a
1983 apollo which is like
foot speed boat with a merc 115 on it
and covering that you know had two
pieces of upholstery had a no sound
system or anything and so it just had
you know a driver's seat which was
upholstered in vinyl totally like miami
lifestyle low freeboard
and then a passenger seat which didn't
even have a back on it was just padded
um and so covering and maintaining that
boat wasn't an issue but when we were
when i was 12 my parents just asked us
we could either have cable tv
or a ski boat
you know because we couldn't afford both
and that's where the evolution came and
trying to take care of a brand new
tournament water ski boat
you know the cover it came with from the
factory you know if you put it on the
boat and there was a rainstorm it would
pool water and then that would stretch
the material and it would drip into the
boat
and then
you know you'd be trailering with one
and it would rip and tear and there'd be
these straps and these poles and all of
this complexity that never kept your
boat dry
or protected from anything
and so
so that was that and then we started to
get older and we started to get nicer
boats with you know the current boat has
you know probably thirty thousand
dollars the current wakeboard bus thirty
thousand dollars of electronics
in it
with touch screens and stuff and then it
has another probably 20 grand in
upholstery like just absurd right these
are 200 000
ferraris that are open top and we're
still using the cover we were trying to
use for the 19
apollo that had two pieces upholstery
and no sound system and so we ended up
in this scenario where we got to a point
where we were having trouble maintaining
our
investments
and and that was a big driving factor
for us and then one day i was out we had
a carport and i had the boat the ski
nautique underneath the carport
and i'm a kite surfer and i was
it was a rainy day and i went to go dry
out my kite so i got it home rinsed it
off reinflated it and i set it on the
boat and i was like
my brother and i were like we were like
why couldn't we build that airframe
underneath the boat cover
and that really like that was the spark
that was like
and then we started building like
prototypes and stuff i started doing it
like at home with a sewing machine like
seven years ago and decided that
technology wasn't there
i definitely didn't have the time or
resources to commit to what it was going
to mean to take this on and we finally
came to a position where my brother had
been engineering down in tesla for 10
years
he
did quite well for himself
retired
and then we started komodo
wow um and so yeah so i'm hearing that
there's sort of this journey went from
you know obviously as a consumer this
frustration and then if there is a spark
of of innovative idea that you're saying
this is something that i want to try out
and and then coupled with
the resources with your brother and when
and your your own ex your own experience
but coming and saying you know this is
actually something that we that we can
do
was that
so so you know taking me back really to
those those initial days where you're
prototyping your building did you
already you know commit sort of to this
journey of komodo was were you just
trying it out and testing and seeing
let's see if this is something that
actually i'm interested in how convicted
were you and what sort of how did your
conviction change over time
oh i was convicted the second i decided
to do it we were going all the way
like there's no i mean i don't
second guessing yourself doesn't seem to
do anything in life and so when we knew
we knew the kite surfing technology
existed we knew we could build an
airframe we know that we can dehumidify
we know we can talk over 4g and wi-fi
and all these things so as soon as the
technology component
was accessible which was kind of an was
kind of an outreach thing you know so
like we went in and to test the validity
of like what it was going to mean to put
this together we made sure that there
were existing technologies
in different sectors that could do what
we needed to do
and then
and that they were somewhat affordable
you know
um and scaled up to volume
and then we just went after it so it was
a hundred percent commitment immediately
um
and you know we did
i've learned some lessons through
running businesses and stuff and the
first thing we did was we went and tried
to build the best foundation possible so
we hired lawyers
you know and
and we wanted komodo to be founded
on the correct principles of business
um before we started so lawyers patent
attorney
you know company structure
um patents and then
we went in and we were kind of in the
background working with a domestic
manufacturer to build prototypes and
stuff but nothing release nothing
launched and so the first thing we did
was just build a inflatable cover
and it wasn't great i'm going to be
honest
with some
and you know as you are
so even at that point so you're saying
you're not building it on the correct
foundation tell me a little bit about
you know then what you were perceiving
as the future challenges so how did you
work through
you know what are going to be the main
challenges for this company is it the is
it the manufacturing is it the
go-to-market strategy the branding trust
i mean what elements did you already
know were going to be critical in the
industry that you're in
you know the marine industry and one of
the reasons we decided to jump on this
is that it's completely empty market
so
so we thought you know like all we have
to do is build a boat cover that's you
know 50 percent better than anything
else on the market so there
the industry had set a pretty low bar
you know
and so we were like well that is a good
industry to be in also high retail
values of these modern boats so
percentage of like our accessory cost to
the percentage cost of the actual asset
i mean was so low i mean one percent
you know to buy to buy a cover two
percent to buy a cover um and then
i thought when we first started that
manufacturing was going to be easier as
it turns out 50-yard textiles
that have very small tolerances are
really hard to build
and so that part gets this lot of a lot
of iterations you know you don't fail
until you stop iterating right exactly
so uh
so you know as
i was
optimistic going in that it could be
done
and i realized from all my experience
managing businesses and developing ecoms
and all these things that i've done in
my life
that like persistence is the most
important thing in startup
i mean you are gonna take hits and
you're gonna take them just constantly
so maintain perspective and work toward
your goals
you know and it's gonna take one or two
things to keep pushing the ball uphill
it's time and money
you know it's just they're they're
synonymous in my mind it's like you know
you got your burn rate and all these
things and so if you want to keep
pushing you need time and money
in weird sometimes you just need another
month or two months sometimes you need
another 200 grand you know and so those
are the things that just keep pushing
the ball up the mountain and you can't
quit
you know you have to keep driving there
there can't be anything that says oh i
can't overcome that problem that mindset
it won't work so if you're looking at
the marine name industry today and you
know go to market is it
sort of this you know similar you know
in e-commerce or in terms of brand
strategy or are there are there specific
things within the marine
niche that that are a little bit
different in in the way that you're
perceiving the strategy
you know in my mind maureen is still
brick and mortar which is crazy right
and so
because of your reliance as a boat owner
on the shop
and your sales person and your service
rider and all of these things your
storage guy you know you're reliant as a
boat owner and there's 12 million
recreational boat owners in the united
states alone
12 million in fiberglass runabouts so
it's insane
they're all reliant on their pro shops
and so our go to market strategy
started off with you know we were just
gonna say hey
you know
we want to be
a dealer to dealer thing so we wanted we
wanted to go and open up dealerships
like a more traditional retail model for
our go to market
rather
because of the nature of boats and the
nature of the marine customer we saw
that as a path forward and then we said
hey three to five years down the line
we want to be building oem covers
because we can make the perfect cover
for a perfect model of boat
not to mention with manufacturing you
know timelines and stuff and deliver
them all
at one point
you know and so
limit the customers we actually sell to
because of the vast majority of skus and
different shapes and sizes of boats we
could focus in and we could open up
specific boats at a time and a boat
needs a new cover every three to five
years so so we have a recurring customer
base
so that makes sense and so internally in
terms of you know leadership and and the
way that the company's grown so where
are you at today with komodo
um so we had a wonderful meeting with a
uh
it all kind of changed up when we got
this opportunity to do oem to start
um and so we had a wonderful meeting and
i'm not going to disclose what brand it
is yet
of course because the ink is definitely
not dry on it uh we had a wonderful
meeting with them and they wanted to
move forward with us
and so that
that's where komodo is at our our first
big meeting where we flew across the
country with the cover and everything um
went quite well
and so so that's where we're currently
at as a company and so most of our focus
is driven on to that brand currently for
for 2023 2024
um
and then we're gonna try to back catalog
sale so sell older models
um direct to dealers
so we can provide our komodo product
on that entire market and so you're so
you went can you you're looking more at
the oem
right and that's so that vertical as the
main growth for for komodo at this point
right that's a
at this point and only because of
opportunities that just came up through
a connection a friend hey you should
meet with these guys they're interested
in your product and so we were planning
on developing you know the number one
you know taking sec taking the sectors
you know the top six models of tow boats
we'll make those first
um and then we'll go out and sell those
direct dealers through this special
portal um and then we were going to move
on to pontoon and center console and run
about and as we
our production our comfortable
production capacity increased we don't
want to put out okay covers
everything
komodo we want to put komodo up there
where it belongs as a premium brand in
the market
and so
we want to take a lot of time and energy
creating the products that are right for
our consumers that are tight and fit
work and
and work perfectly
so that takes a little bit more time to
create those covers takes more
iterations
uh takes us actually going and using
them
um and because of that we were just
gonna step our way up and add more and
more models and then those customers you
know people
average lifespan of awake boats between
25 and 35 years
like so we're in it for the long game we
want to be a staple brand in the marine
industry with innovative technologies
hopefully that answered yeah and and so
if you're looking out a bit about
yourself and so your your own experience
going through this is it what you
imagined more or less well what kind of
what kind of thoughts do you have now
about about you know leadership in this
domain for you
you know i it's the first time i've ever
been like truly happy at work
um
it's
definitely the most pressure i've ever
experienced you know in startup world i
mean everything is kind of make or break
you know it where's the next investment
coming from you know if we don't get
this deal what are we going to pivot to
you know you're always running your abc
plans
in your head and looking at what the
budgets and the burn rates
all correlate to all those plans and you
know planning for the worst case
scenario hoping for the best case
scenario and
and just trying to keep
the car down on the road
you know
and so it's been really really
fulfilling and gratifying and like this
amazing experience but i also like have
like
way more gray hairs than i did when i
started this
um and you know manufacturing is
difficult and textile manufacturing is
not injection holding and we're in
telecom 4g wi-fi i mean we we populate
and bake our own pcbs in-house you know
we have an electronics lab and a textile
design
space and a full maker space you know
they're 3d printers last month our power
bill just for 3d printers was like 65
dollars in just 3d printing costs like
in power like it's just insane and so
you
you keep iterating and building pieces
and trying to figure out how to make
additive manufacturing airtight and
watertight
you know so you know you've got the
glues and i'm down there in the shop
paint you know my engineers are like hey
i need someone to paint this with epoxy
and i'm like i'll paint it with them see
you know so it's it's being that's right
and my team's and it sounds like you so
you also you have both a grasp on you
know building current product but also
continuously making sure that you're
innovating and and that
that you're that you're leveraging you
know whatever tools we have at our
disposal in 2022 to do that and it
sounds like that's exactly what you're
doing with the 3d and manufacturing
right
yeah i mean additive manufacturing is so
cool i mean it definitely has its
pitfalls you know you're no it's not an
epson you're not printing 2d on a piece
of paper you know i mean fortunately we
just got the new ryze 3d pro 3 printers
which have auto leveling beds and better
temperature control which is not
something i knew about three years ago
by the way uh and like and like they do
make it easier but also printer settings
and all these things
you know i thought
when i bought my first 3d printer that
you just throw the cat on in there hit
the print button you know and then you
start
and you start like talking about like
how you can't put supports in there and
you can't actually print it like that
unless we want to use like dual head
printing with dissolving supports
you know and like like those sorts of
things were so much harder
than i thought they were gonna be they
took so much longer and then covet
you know just just throw that one on
there and uh
and uh it's been an interesting couple
of years and it has been i can only
imagine and very quickly it sounds
really really interesting
i i just love learning about these
things that i have no idea about and
don't meet them in in the day-to-day and
i really want to thank you for for
coming on and and sharing these 20
minutes with me a little bit about your
journey about your thought process how
this whole thing started and where
you're at today so josh thank you very
very much best of luck with komodo and
and i look forward to
to experiencing one of these boats
myself sounds great
all right well thank you for having me
uh if you want to chat again let me know
we're here thank you very much josh
thank you
bye take care
you